AGAIN, DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
DISCUSS IT.
IT'S
MILLSAP, BIG FINISH!
PAUL MILLSAP IN THE FINISH.
TOUGH SHOT FOR BOSTON.
HE GOTTHAT!
YOUR MAN BRANDON BOSTON
WINDMILL, DUNK.
[ LAUGHTER ] UTAH TRYING TO THE.
REGGIE JACKSON!
ARE YOU READY FOR YOUR
CLOSE-UP?
[ CR
>> PASS UNDER TO FACU -- OVER
THE SHOULDER, MORRISE
DEFENDS AND AS TOUGH AS HE IS.
>> Stan:
A LOSS.
>> Eric: THAT MAY BE
>> Dell: IT IS OKAY TO SMILE
WHEN YOU DO STUFF LIKE BACKUP 1
STEAL.
WHEN YOU SEE THIS, IT SHOULD
MAKEKE
FIGURES WITH 10.  OF A FLEX IN .
YEAH, TAKE THAT TYLER HERRO.GAM.
CAUGHT A BODYCHASED DOWN AND HE
COMBO. IT
HARD, LITTLE SOFTER IN IT
AGAINST ORLANDO, IT'S NOT HOW
YOU PLAY IT WITH
STEPH  CORNER.
KUZMA FOR INTENDED.
[ LAUGHTER ] A
SHOW.
YOU DON'T WANT THAT HAPPENI
THE FOUL.AS A SPARTAN.
ZACH RANDOLPH AS A SPARTAN.